i had no expectations going into blue  miracle on netflix  but i was thoroughly impressed by this  film it shows you that pg films  can still be really good and are still  important to have it's a great family  movie  but what really works about it is that  it hits all the notes you have to hit in  a family movie effectively where  it's constantly giving you good laughs  at land it's heartfelt it's based off a  true story  it's inspiring but it really gives you  hope by the end and you will have some  tears for sure but dennis quaid  has a great performance here and the  lead jimmy gonzalez is fantastic as our  main character  i think this is surprise hit of the year  and it's gonna be  the pg film to beat for this year and  i think it's definitely worth the watch  of the whole family on netflix